[Musique]
allez
c'est avec joie au nom de notre empereur
je vous souhaite à tous la bienvenue
pardo reparle vous êtes au rire elle
vous plaît tenez elle était fou c'est ma
fille pourquoi tu frappes argos
partir de maintenant c'est moi votre
chef
on m'a dit que j'allais travailler
je me suis retrouvé au bord des d'une
base militaire japonaise
yoo nak-joon ancien leader coréen est
détenu à hashim à votre mission le
récupérer
aucun gorée un témoin de ce qui s'est
passé ici ne doivent sortir vivant de
cette île
vous direz qu'ils ont été transférés à
nagasaki pour y être soignés
je t'en supplie mais brûle toi ce que ma
fille puisse quitter ashima
nous devons fuir et ne laisser aucun de
nos frères ici
nous montrera la maison évidemment
ils vont bientôt embarquer on va aller
les couvrir
une seule d'entre nous s'en sortent
ce sera déjà une grande victoire
chez nous
[Musique]
et ça